I went to the store on the wrong night
and I come walking in and the host just
goes uh-oh and I go what she goes you
were supposed to be here tomorrow night
I said all right whatever gives a [__]
I'm just popping in I'll do this thing
we go okay it's a benefit though I'm
like all right they go it's for battered
women and I said all right I know how to
work around that right
so I go out there so I just keep making
references to getting beaten you know
you guys you know I didn't get shook
like you guys did but I'm just being an
[__] and whatever I just kept making
these references to getting beaten right
and then finally they figured it out so
I mean the back goes
I'm towards the end of my set they just
go we're not battered we're alcoholics
oh my God I I don't know what I heard
and then I said oh I was like you guys
you guys are drunks all right these are
my people and they all laugh and I was
like holy [__] I go you know I've had
problem with alcohol you know and then I
just was like you know I'm not like you
guys I wasn't like running out of it and
sucking dick for it I mean I you know